[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de nuestra
salud en directo américa para ello ya
está conmigo ya como todos los días en
el estudio más romeros a la mar
bienvenida muy buen día feliz jueves
para ti vamos a empezar con la noticia
que estábamos adelantando sobre las
pastillas de la farmacéutica merck
contra el hobbit 19 que todavía no están
aprobadas pero hay expectativa para su
distribución pues faltaría más de hecho
porque recordemos que es un tratamiento
que puede reducir hasta en un 50% el
riesgo de hospitalización por kobe y que
además está en formato pastillas por lo
tanto es muy fácil de distribuir hay
muchísima expectativa y del acuerdo no
es una cierta buena noticia no agarre
alrededor del acceso al medicamento es
un acuerdo con el fondo común de
patentes de medicamentos una
organización respaldada por la onu para
que haya otros países y otros
fabricantes que puedan hacer el mismo
medicamento en versiones genéricas y por
lo tanto más accesibles ahora mismo el
acuerdo ya incluye 24 compañías de 105
países de ingresos medios y bajos y es
la primera decisión de este tipo en la
pandemia es decir no ha pasado con las
vacunas por ahora que se liberen
relativamente las patentes para que
otras personas puedan los mismos
medicamentos las mismas herramientas
contra el cob y decimos relativa porque
de hecho médicos sin fronteras ha
criticado parte de esta decisión porque
dice que excluye algunos países como
brasil como china que son fabricantes
potenciales de este medicamento que
podrían hacerlo mucho más accesible y lo
que piden es que no haya ningún tipo de
restricción territorial el miedo es de
hecho que pase lo mismo que está pasando
con las vacunas que es que se
distribuyan de manera muy desigual
alrededor de todo el mundo y por eso
vamos a repasar ahora pues cómo va la
distribución de merck todo esto
recordemos sin que se haya todavía
aprobado definitivamente el tratamiento
por ahora la farmacéutica ha prometido
ya fabricar 10 millones de tratamientos
para 2021 antes de que se termine el año
y de estos ya hay un 30% que están
reservados por acuerdos de compra
bilaterales con países del mayor como
cabía esperar es de eeuu que ya ha
reservado 17 millones del 17% del total
de los tratamientos y pagos 700 dólares
por cada tratamiento cuando cuando
decimos tratamiento nos referimos a que
con eso puedes tratar a una persona son
10 pastillas para tratar a una persona
entonces bueno tenemos que estar muy
pendientes porque esto puede ser un gran
avance en la lucha contra la pandemia y
así es ojalá se garantice que todos
accedamos a eso ojalá ya vamos a ver qué
pasa pero seguimos hablando de la
pandemia y la buena noticia de la caída
de los contagios en nuestro continente
pero no estamos libres de kobe todavía
no es una es una buena noticia relativa
por un lado de hecho por ejemplo en
bogotá ayer no se registró ninguna
muerte por condicionar por primera vez
desde prácticamente el inicio de la
pandemia por lo tanto bueno las cifras
están a la baja en todo el continente
americano eso es una buena noticia pero
la parte agridulce siempre hay un avión
por el lado de la vacunación aunque se
duplicó desde agosto del mes pasado
hasta esta semana ahora mismo hay un 44
por ciento de la población inmunizada en
todo el continente americano la
organización panamericana de la salud
sigue diciendo que estemos alerta
escuchemos lo que dicen aunque nuestra
región ha hecho una gran labor para
acelerar esta cobertura de inmunización
en sólo unos cuantos meses más de la
mitad de las personas en américa latina
y el caribe siguen sin protección en
guatemala se empiecen y las granadinas
jamaica paraguay haití menos del 20 por
ciento de las personas han sido
plenamente vacunadas todos estos países
que están mencionando como guatemala
jamaica nicaragua haití de hecho van a
ser los prioritarios para la
distribución de vacunas de 3 millones de
dosis por el mecanismo kóvacs que van a
llegar en principio esta semana dato
importante que estaba dando la misma hoy
ps es que la mayoría de vacunas que han
llegado a américa latina han sido a
través de donaciones bilaterales oa
través de donaciones de kóvacs eso resta
un montón de autonomía mucha autonomía a
los países para decidir cómo implementan
estas campañas de inmunización y las
desigualdades siguen por ejemplo en
haití es el país con menos tasa de
vacunación menos de un 1 por ciento de
la población ahora mismo está inmunizada
usted tocaba haití y continúa la crisis
en ese país porque ahora afecta la salud
de la población en esa parte de la isla
sí como hemos venido explicando hay una
crisis de combustible grande que afecta
muchísimos aspectos de la sociedad
haitiana pero una de las más graves es
la red hospitalaria por ejemplo
estábamos hablando de estas vacunas que
van que van a llegar no hay manera de
refrigerar las por ejemplo ni de
mantenerlas si no hay electricidad para
mantener las neveras funcionando pero
bueno más allá del cob y hay muchas
otras enfermedades que están quedando
desatendidas y hay testimonios que
llegan desde haití como por ejemplo de
médicos sin fronteras que explican la
dramática situación que se está viviendo
escuchemos lo
la reciente escasez de combustible en
haití amenaza el acceso y la continuidad
de la atención médica en el país en el
hospital traumatológico de tabal puerto
príncipe- médicos sin fronteras se ha
visto obligado a limitar los pacientes y
tratar solo las emergencias que pongan
la vida en peligro otras estructuras
médicas tanto privadas como públicas han
debido interrumpir sus servicios
y esto es en el médico sin fronteras que
tienen unos ciertos recursos que tienen
generadores que están pudiendo funcionar
pero la situación es mucho peor en la
red local de hecho la agencia efe
reporta que ya hay 50 centros
hospitalarios que han debido cerrar han
debido cerrar por la falta de
combustible que pasa por ejemplo los
trabajadores sanitarios no están
pudiendo llegar a los hospitales la
mayoría de cirugías no se están pudiendo
realizar y hay unidades especialmente
críticas como por ejemplo las
pediátricas o las de neonatos que no
están pudiendo dar el cuidado que
necesitan los pacientes precisamente por
esa falta de combustible todo esto se
traduce en una imposibilidad de prevenir
muertes que de otra manera se podrían
estar evitando lamentable mar la
situación de salud en haití como pues la
política y también la socia muchísimas
gracias por toda la información mañana
más salud en directo américa